في هذه الاثناء بدا انصار المجلس الاعلى
لنظرات البيجاف في الشرق اغلاق طرق السفر
في ولايتي كسلا والبحر الاحمر وذلك رفضا
للاتفاق السياسي وقال مناصرون للمجلس الذي
يقوده محمد الامين ترك
وبعض التنظيمات المتحالفه معه للعربيه انه
بداوا بوضع الحواجز في الطرقات ومنع
الشاحنات من العبور الى بقيه الولايات
وقال محمد ادم القيادي في الجبهه الشعبيه
المتحده للتحرير والعداله في تصريحات
للعربيه قال ان الاغلاق سيستمر حتى اشعار
اخر هذا وتناهض تنظيمات سياسيه شرق البلاد
الاتفاق الايطالي الموقع في الخامس من
ديسمبر الماضي وتهدد باسقاطه واسقاط
الحكومه المدنيه التي ستنتج عنها
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم مديره مكتب العربيه
في السودان لينا يعقوب اهلا بك يا لينا
معنا مره اخرى
لينا ما هي فرص التوصل نجاح هذا الاجتماع
اليوم وتوصل الى اتفاق بشان او توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي
وخصوصا اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار المعارضه
لهذا الاتفاق في شرق السودان
اهلا بك يا راويه هناك فرص ربما للحل هذا
الاجتماع الذي من المقرر ان يعقد في هذه
اللحظات تدخله قوه من الحريه والتغيير
الاليه الثلاثيه رئيس مجلس السياده طبعا
ونائبه وكذلك ثلاثه من اعضاء المجلس
السيادي باعتبارهم موقعين على الوثيقه
الدستوريه عفوا على الوثيقه السياسيه هنا
لابد ان نشير راويه الى ان هذه القوه
اليوم تدفع بمقترح وهي معلومه جديده عن
يتم هذا التوقيع في السادس من ابريل كانت
هناك جداول زمنيه موضوعه ان يتم التوقيع
الاتفاق السياسي في مطلع ابريل توقيع
الدستور الانتقالي في السادس من ابريل
توقيع او اعلان رئيس الوزراء في الحادي
عشر ايضا من هذا الشهر الان هذه القوه
تدفع بمقترح ان يؤجل توقيع اليوم الى
السادس من ابريل
المكون العسكري وتحديدا نقصد هنا الجيش
السوداني يرى انه لا يرغب في الدخول في
تواقيت جديده انما يرغب في حل هذه المشكله
المتمثله بوضع جدول زمني لدمج الدعم
السريع داخل الجيش هل سيسهم الاطراف اليوم
ومن بينهم الاليه الثلاثيه في تقريب وجهات
النظر بان يتم حل هذه الاشكاليه وان يتم
التوقيع في السادس من ابريل هذا ربما ما
سنعلمه بعد انتهاء هذا الاجتماع